[Música]
en buenas tardes mi nombre es roberto y
es un honor estar invitado a este evento
tan importante una plática te diademas
en nuestra universidad en la uap un
gusto pues como ya lo platicaban la
intención es desde mi visión empresarial
emprendedora poner a su consideración
una iniciativa que tiene que ver con
innovación la innovación adecuada a
nuestra cultura nuestra manera de ser a
nuestra manera de actuar
tenemos muchos retos en mexico y ustedes
lo saben lo saben los jóvenes lo lo
saben inequidad pobreza dijo que un
rezago tremendo con el 60 ó 70 parte de
ese 170 por ciento de la población en
méxico y yo estoy cierto que con la
innovación dadas las características de
nuestro país este con muchas
oportunidades muchas potencialidades
pero un país todavía en vías de
desarrollo pues pareciera que la
innovación es clave de innovación este
puede ser el gran cambio el gran
potencializador la palanca que nos
empuje precisamente eso no a lograr
menos inequidad que el suelo esté más
más parejo recordarán este hace poco y a
cada rato el sector empresarial
comentamos que la única manera de abatir
la pobreza es creando riqueza pero a
algunos se les olvida que es creando
riqueza compartida compartiendo les
decir que la riqueza que generamos como
sector empresarial por supuesto llega
todos los a todos los stakeholders en la
siguiente diapositiva que quiero
aparecer por ahí este hablaba de la de
cómo somos los mexicanos y las dos
maneras de solucionar es de los
problemas ustedes la mayoría son
estudiantes aunque cuando vas a llegar a
presentar un examen yo no tenemos dedos
no tenemos la solución técnica pues que
es básicamente aplicarte en el semestre
estudiar una semana antes meterle el
último empujón o la milagrosa no
simplemente este pues no estudiar nunca
ir a clase que yo soy maestro y nos
pasan alumnos que nunca llegan más que
un día antes de la del examen y además
creer que van a pasarlo bien la
milagrosa no van a haber hecho las
maravillas alguna imagen milagrosa que
por supuesto que ayuda pero no tanto si
nunca fuiste no lo vas a solventar esto
es bueno pero primera esta postura que
pongo es consideración
tenemos dos maneras los mexicanos los
hispanos los latinos de solucionar la
técnica y la milagrosa no segundo y
aunque en todo proceso
este educativo profesional estarán de
acuerdo que hay dos caminos el orden y
el caos es más me había permitido poner
dos fotografías una de un metro no nos
ni 15 verdad qué país estaban todos
ordenaditos para subirse al metro y otra
fotografía del metro de ciudad de méxico
aquí en puebla no tenemos metro nombre
pues caótico no o sea todos empujando se
nos tienen que dividir hombres y mujeres
etcétera y comentaba que hay que
reconocer somos por naturaleza por
cultura por origen un poquito caóticos o
sin embargo el caos no necesariamente es
malo no el caos genera condiciones
finalmente de creación la mayoría de
innovaciones se crea en el momento de
caos
más adelante daré algunos ejemplos
entonces bueno el caos hay que
reconocerlo no es malo genera ecosistema
perfecto para la creatividad nada más no
no exageres no esto es bueno ya
entendimos lo primero hay una milagrosa
o la técnica segunda hay la
y el orden y el agua que sirve la
innovación desde mi visión emprendedora
sirve para atender necesidades reales es
decir la principal diferencia de
inventar e innovar para un emprendedor
es que el que inventa es que atiende
necesidades reales del mercado el
inventor no el inventor crea cosas que
mejor el mercado no las está no las está
esté requiriendo los que nos toca para
sacar adelante a nuestro méxico crear
valor y valor compartido valor para
todos no sólo para unos a unos poquitos
pero este valor como lo podemos generar
innovando a partir de donde pues de
nuestra técnica milagrosa de nuestra
técnica de un poquito del caos les puse
la técnica y la milagrosa muchos de
ustedes imagino que usan la milagrosa en
los exámenes bueno ahí están las fotos
del metro no les mentí caos y orden y
además hay dos modos si usted cada uno
usted reconocerá cuál funciona más el de
la expiración y el de la inspiración
inspiración musa este cualquiera de tus
hijos no sentado pensando y sin hacer
nada no de puntas que haces
me estoy inspirando se vale porque es tu
motor es tu motivo lo que te mueve
emprender pero yo creo que sin
expiración es decir sin sudar la sin
levantarle lazos de levantarte las
mangas y hacer que las cosas pasen pues
la inspiración no sirve de nada cuál es
más importante yo creo que las 22 bueno
invitarlos tenemos tres caminos no es
pura inspiración o por expiración una
mezcla rica puro orden o puro caos o una
mezcla rica una milagrosa ola o la
técnica a una mezcla rica pues buscamos
la mezcla rica y creo que se llama
intuición estratégica básicamente mezcla
dos modelos el modelo de la intuición
del melate yo creo que nos encantan los
emprendedores no tenemos emprendedores
porque crees que te van a comprar el
producto y te dice pues no sé yo siento
algo aquí en
el estómago y en cambio el estratega te
dice pues tengo un estudio de mercado el
mercado vale tanto voy a tomar esta
rebanada del pastel etcétera no y se me
ocurrió poner dos ejemplos interesantes
de lo que es este intuición y de lo que
es estrategia intuición recordarán han
visto este en televisión
a mamá lucha hacia mí no si no se llama
lucha que tal hasta que le jala la oreja
y todo al hijo que intuición tiene la
madre mexicana brutal que amarilla no
tiene estudios ni nada voy a saber
perfectamente cuando le miente un hijo
no ella sabe perfectamente si trae
aliento alcohólico los chavos que
piensen que llegas despacito en la
loncha y no te va a cachar tu mamá
ya va te lleva tres pasos adelante no la
intuición de la madre mexicana es
bárbara y puso otra foto napoleón
bonaparte no que dicen que es uno de los
reyes de la estrategia gana webber es el
planear las cosas piense en apoyo no se
vuelve famoso porque
está atacando lo están atacando en un
castillo en francia un ejército este
extranjero inglés quiero recordar y eran
más que el que hace manda un grupo a
quemar de los barcos a los ingleses no
ahora que serás mucho pero estás en
tierra extranjera y no te puedes
regresar
eso es estrategia y es dar dos pasos
atrás atrás del problema y ver no pero
bueno entonces platican a su mamá y su
mamá te decía yo no sé traes aliento
alcohólico entonces que nos conviene
mezclar la intuición pues finalmente con
la estrategia y quiero platicar los
algunos ejemplos globales locales y de
varios periodos de en el tiempo de lo
que puede ser la intuición es
estratégica nosotros aquí en méxico le
llamamos intuición intuición experta se
imaginen la visión de una mamá de ese
feeling ese me late con un poquito de
técnica un poquito de orden un poquito
de este estudios de mercado
y te vuelves imparable primer ejemplo
henry ford no este es creador del primer
carro que era accesible para todos no es
un acción decía yo tengo que lograr que
un colaborador un trabajador un obrero
mío sea capaz de comprar mi carro no el
modelo el modelo t pero bueno él es
famoso por este y cómo se llama lo que
hacen en serie la producción producción
en serie aunque algunos dicen que ya
existía pero vamos a decir que el freno
en su biografía es muy interesante él
comenta que frente a su casa había un
rastro y que la adolescente lo visitaba
y él estaba admirado de la efectividad
del carnicero no en el cual la red se
movía y el carnicero permanecía parado
no lo que eficienta va a temas de
energía además te volvía experto que
hace cuando inicia el proyecto de carros
trae con intuición el tema del rastro y
lo aplica con técnica a la producción en
serie de automóviles en el cual no se
mueve el obrero como ocurría antes si no
se mueve el automóvil y existe
especialización quien según dato
interesante de el proceso de
automatización que estamos viviendo
seguramente en pocos años el que se va a
mover es el carro pero ya sin obreros no
seguramente el carro
autónomo esté lleno acción estar se
descompongan llantas y la computadora el
carro va a poder caminar sin línea de
montaje por todo una fábrica irse hasta
estacionar al final no con un tema de
desplazamiento de mano de obra el
segundo thomas alva edison
este que inventó thomas alva edison
sino la bombilla eléctrica pues no es
cierto y hace que el intento no intento
nunca le salió le gana un poco que no
use la patente y él
en un acto de sensatez de humildad de
intuición él dice mejor voy la compro
entonces va a buscar un bar y evans y le
compra la patente no para que para
aplicaciones técnicas es decir en él
también cupo la intuición o sea salió el
mamá lucha digamos de de thomas alva
edison para ir y comprar finalmente la
patente y lo importante es que lo
recordamos ahora como el creador de la
bombilla eléctrica alguien a quien yo
admiro mucho falleció hace dos años no
lorenzo servitje sendra de fundador del
grupo bimbo y de un montón de
iniciativas sociales
tienen debiendo frescura y don lorenzo
de viva voz' tuve el honor de escuchar
lo que nos platicaba dos anécdotas la
primera cuando una chamaco 18 19 años y
en los años 40 se ha de un pan se mueve
el pan ideal este imaginen en méxico los
40 no no había cadenas frías no había
este tiendas de conveniencia había
tendajones este pequeños como los que
existen en la calle no es la bronca del
pan de barra de ese tiempo que venía por
cierto en una bolsa como este color café
no veías el interior era que llegabas a
tu casa y era muy posible que estuviera
echado a perder vigencia la intuición la
ahora sí que la parte de mamá lucha de
don lorenzo como solución hace eso es un
joven no tienes una gran empresa todavía
pero detectas un problema real de
mercado y lo quiere solucionar iniciado
en ourense donde puse bolsa transparente
no le pone bolsa es el fan transparente
y es el primer elemento innovador este
de que funda yo creo que ahora es una
gran empresa
como es bimbo y otro que nos decía hace
poco don lorenzo antes de que falleciera
y platicaba de barcel él decía que
estaban buscando un producto innovador
que conectará con él con él
millennial que apenas estaba empezando a
consumirlo y don lorenzo igual la mamá
lucha de lorenzo salirse con ese
platillo que más como el mexicano
tacos dice por qué no hacemos una papa
en forma de taco y generan el producto
que ustedes ya saben takis este fuego
takis bears etcétera a partir de algo
tan obvio y tan sencillo que es más si
lo escuchamos de alguien no le darías
importancia no crea papas en forma de
está aquí y creo que es un trancazo no
les apuesto que la mayoría de millones
aquí les encantan los sabores y la forma
en la que la textura de los tacos de don
lorenzo no y uno más que que aparte es
bien cuestionable don amancio ortega de
sara este yo tuve el gusto de conocer la
persona que le decían los casos que nos
presentará en en la vida de columbia
nueva york y lo que ellos hacen lo que
inditex ase con sara es que manda su
gente a las pasarelas de los grandes
diseñadores observan las tendencias las
modas etcétera se regresan de volada el
taller
por supuesto hace modificaciones legales
para que no haya un problema de derechos
de autor patentes qué sé yo y a las
pocas semanas de que lo vieron la
pasarela lo tenemos aquí en usar a guau
no como una parte de intuición pero otra
gran parte de estrategia no es te hacen
un copy cat
legal trayendo democratizando la moda él
dice que se dedica a vender este moda
rápida no y bueno y finalmente este que
significa innovar potencializar nuestros
talentos no es decir no vamos a tapar
esa ese tema mexicano creativo latino
que tenemos nada más que analicemos bien
que yo estoy en temas de zinc a eso me
dedico qué tal este del toro que tal
cuarón que está línea rito no con temas
altamente creativos platicando historias
universales y sus películas no son sólo
para méxico no son obviamente para todo
finalmente para todo el mundo
hoy posee una foto de ustedes el capital
en todos los de los jóvenes ustedes los
millennials son parteaguas para méxico
de verdad ustedes van a cambiar el rumbo
si ustedes dedican su esfuerzo de
innovación podemos atender el tema de
pobreza podemos atender el tema de
inequidad que tanto está doliendo éste
finalmente finalmente a nuestro país el
encierro con una frase que han dicho a
varios precios escuché en este escenario
a don arnoldo de la rocha de pollo feliz
esté en la iglesia tan elegante de
nuestro origen o determina nuestro
destino él decía nacer en méjico nacer
no determina que mueras no
de dónde vienes no depende de nosotros
pero para dónde vamos y donde acabemos
eso sí depende de ti y es parte clave de
la innovación pues bueno nos tocó nacer
acá en un país bellísimo con un montón
de potencialidades con un bono
demográfico enorme de jóvenes talentosos
como ustedes que nos toca pues tomar la
buena
lo bueno tradición
es mamá lucha el consejo de la mamá del
papá del primo prometerle técnica no
meterle estudios de mercado meterle un
plan de acción etcétera de manera que a
través de la innovación pues logremos un
un mejor país y muchísimas gracias por
su atención
[Música]